this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so what I'm saying is that
we're gonna split the talk into two
halves I'm gonna give the first half
then headed off to Yolanda and the first
half I'm gonna talk about is a little
bit about our position and then mostly
about New York City and urban
agriculture in New York City and then
you wander we'll talk about the
challenges that we found as we've been
working with people over the last year
so New York City you haven't you don't
know about it is big it's very big it's
three hundred and four square miles and
as far as its sort of physically
compared to upstate New York the winters
are milder the summers are hotter we
have a moderating effect of the ocean
being there it's also further south and
we have the urban heat island effect and
that's a big factor that we're still
sort of figuring out what that has to do
with urban agriculture but it can mean
for example that in the summertime it
means hotter peak temperatures in
afternoon and it means warmer nights in
summer so sometimes as much as seven
degrees Fahrenheit warmer than just
outside the city so that that can be a
big factor that we're still sort of
figuring out and then also it's
obviously very populous biggest city in
the country most densely populated city
in the country and by pretty wide margin
and very culturally diverse and that
comes with I mean you can see a little
bit from this map which is kind of
overwhelming so I could spend too much
time on it but you can see a little bit
from the each color being different
racial ethnic groups that there's some
segregation built into the end of the
city like historical segregation and
structural inequalities that come with
that and that overlays a lot with the
work that we do and then there's just
high cost of living in the city and
that's sort of a fact of life in New
York and it it sort of plays a big role
in a lot of different ways that bourbon
agriculture takes shape as well so our
position we this position was created
just a year ago so we started just a
little over a year ago the program
didn't exist before that in the city so
Yolanda and I were hired to be the urban
agriculture specialists in New York City
and basically bring agricultural
extension into into the city
our sort of central focus is to build
educational programs and and other
support for commercial urban agriculture
and we'll talk a little bit more about
what what we mean by commercial or what
what the description means but mostly
it's an it's a you know an extension
position doing program development and a
lot of individual technical assistance
and manual labor as you can see here we
so New York urban or New York City urban
agriculture takes a lot of different
forms we are dealing primarily with what
we're calling commercial urban
agriculture what we're classifying as
commercial which is for-profit and and
privately owned operations like you
would expect but also includes a lot of
nonprofits which are growing produce and
selling it and it goes back into their
budgets so we're including them as well
it's a different structure but it's
still we're still calling it commercial
and it also includes a lot of very small
operations backyards and people selling
you know a thousand dollars worth of
tomatoes within their community that
counts as well but beyond that they're
also when I could spends much time on it
today but very important other forms of
urban agriculture in the city and
community gardens are really big
presence I'll talk about that the next
slide but also there a lot of other
nonprofits that aren't selling what
they're growing or aren't selling very
much and most of their food is being
donated to schools to food pantries or
just sort of within the community
community gardens are sort of the
foundation of urban agriculture in New
York City they've been around for a long
time and I mean a very long time and the
sort of present-day community garden
movement in the city really took off in
the 70s and 80s and had a lot to do with
green space preservation and that
remains a really important role of
community gardens in the city there are
over 700 in total throughout the city
this map just shows green thumb' gardens
which is sort of the division of the New
York City Parks Department so they run
the largest portion of them but they're
another one or two hundred that aren't
even on this map but you can see
concentrations of them this is in
central and eastern Brooklyn
and in the Bronx and in Harlem so when
we talk about the operations we work
with more often the farms and the market
gardens you can see a little bit of
overlap where these this blue which is
nonprofit sites and up here to overlap
some with where the gardens are they
tend to be in the similar neighborhoods
and that there's a lot of those to go
hand-in-hand and some of the community
gardens are sort of function as a
nonprofit farm which is a whole other
sort of topic but you'll also see that
the red dots the for-profit enterprises
are serve a cluster here in northern
Brooklyn and that is a lot of hydroponic
operations that are in this sort of
industrial zones and then they're
scattered around the city so we've
worked we found 34 35 so far and we
think there are others that's fit this
description so the nonprofit's like I
said they are growing spaces operated by
mission driven nonprofits mission
besides food production
so education workforce development food
justice to social justice and so some of
the food is sold for project revenue a
lot of that money goes right back into
paying farm staff so that's one of the
reasons we we do think of it as a
commercial enterprise because it or as a
commercial agriculture because it is
economic development a very direct way
and one thing that you find that we find
out a lot of the nonprofit operations is
crops being grown with the neighboring
community in mind often because the
neighboring community is participating
and so that includes for example an
eastern or central Brooklyn there's a
large Caribbean community so there are a
lot of amaranth greens growing for
callaloo bitter melon which was brought
up from the West Indies and all over the
city there's a lot of collard greens and
then the other serve category is the
for-profit and privately owned
operations the majority of the indoor
and hydroponic operations fall into this
category but they're also also the soil
based rooftop farms are more
before profit for profit businesses are
more likely to be growing high-value
products in the city so high-end salad
greens like you see here at Gotham
greens Oh actually that's basil well
high-end salad greens and herbs they do
both and also specialty specialty
enterprises like mushrooms this on the
bottom they grow this is all hot peppers
and then in order to supplement the
revenue because it's difficult to make
up the to make enough in income just
from selling produce in the city there
will be supplementary revenue from
hosting events consulting on other
projects and people people will pay to
do tours and workshops on the sites and
also some of these projects especially
the hydroponic ones will have venture
capital behind them which we'll get into
more so the other way that we sort of
look at the two different or another way
of dividing the the categorizing the
urban agriculture enterprises in this
city is sort of indoor versus outdoor to
kind of oversimplify it and so indoor
being in our case sort of shorthand for
a controlled environment agriculture or
CEA
which is an acronym will probably say a
few more times this is these mostly
hydroponic operations again greens and
herbs most commonly a lot of them are
startup startup enterprises with
investors investment behind them either
the owner put their own capital into it
and they had a lot of capital or they
brought in venture capital and this
includes a lot of or a few alternative
enterprises which include aquaculture
and mushrooms and I should mention this
last this is square roots which is one
that gets a bit of press this is in a
shipping container in Brooklyn there are
a bunch of shipping containers this is
just one of them and then the other side
of that operation type being the soil
based or outdoor farms which can be at
ground level or some of them are on
rooftop on rooftops where they brought
the soil up these are more likely to be
nonprofit or maybe they're for-profit
but they have a mission a similar
mission
sort of built into it and they're more
likely to be diversified vegetable
operations so really this this example
here's that and I own family farm is
obviously it's on Staten Island and it's
one that you walk around there and
Augustine the farmer has been there for
twenty years
it's an acre or so of what it looks like
just a miniaturized diversified
vegetable farm that could have been at
the Hudson Valley and so there are a
number of farms sort of like that in
especially around the edges of the city
where there's more land available and/or
where there's basically any land
available that you can farm right into
that ground but there there are a lot of
different source or based operations and
so a side note on that is that actually
the majority of these that we found in
the city are not growing in the soil the
native soil on the site and even when it
is native soils very often actually fill
dredged it brought in from the bay or
construction fill but two-thirds or more
of the sort of soil based sites that we
found are growing in imported soils or
sort of soil like media like purchased
topsoil from from nurseries which is
often mixed with compost or heavily
amended afterwards with compost rooftop
mixes so the rooftop farms will add some
to have a really lightweight blend in
order to meet the weight requirements of
the roof which comes with its own sort
of challenges and then actually the
biggest piece of this pie here is a
hundred percent compost which is the
that's the most common single sort of
growing media in the in the city the
city gives away the Department of
Sanitation gives away bagged compost for
free from they're sort of big municipal
compost site so it's a very high carbon
as far as we can tell very high carbon
compost a lot of like woodchips and leaf
litter and stuff and so because it's
given away for free a lot of people use
that as their primary growing medium and
that raised a whole lot of other
interesting questions which is a
slideshow in itself we won't get into
and then so here's a map of those
differentiating those two different
types of operations the lighter green
being the the hydroponic and CEA
operations darker green about being soil
based as you can see that a lot of the
dark green dots the soy-based are more
around the fringes of the city and the
hydroponics are especially in that
cluster in northern brooklyn and finally
to divide the sort of looking at the two
again indoor/outdoor being a shorthand
for those two different groups you can
see the difference in enterprises
outdoor again um the dark blue is the
sort of primary enterprise of slice to
be visited and light blue beings or an
additional secondary enterprises or side
enterprises so outdoor enterprises or
outdoor operations focus on diversified
vegetables in almost every case often
because it's part of their mission
rather than because it's the most
profitable thing and but they also have
a whole lot of secondary enterprises
including a lot of herbs cut flowers we
see honey and eggs and some perennial
fruits to indoor enterprises are more
focused less diversified and again
focusing on high-value for the space and
high turnover so herbs especially basil
high end salad greens mostly lettuce and
microgreens and then a few alternative
enterprises so we see some room for
growth or additional enterprises down
the road in especially fish or
aquaculture and mushrooms and there's
one person growing spirulina and we'll
see how that goes so at this point I'm
gonna head it off to Yolanda all right I
don't have a mic so I'm just gonna be
using this so now that we have kind of a
general overview the different types of
urban agriculture this portion is gonna
be focusing on the challenges both soil
based and CEA controlled environment
agriculture so when we started about a
year ago in October of 2017 we really
wanted to get a better sense of how we
were gonna direct our efforts in New
York City so we conducted an in-form
all needs assessment and we visited and
interviewed 25 different commercial
operations had discussions with other
stakeholders including non commercial
farms and gardens and also consulted
with a few urban AG leaders may be
familiar with Karen Washington and other
AG service providers in the city like
grow NYC and just food and we also did
some background research on other urban
AG surveys and assessments may be
familiar with the five borough farm
project just to build off of what's
already the research that's already
taking place so the challenges can
really be summed into three main
categories space funding and knowledge
and these upcoming slides are just gonna
dive deeper into the specifics of each
of those challenges so within soil based
operations space is obviously a huge
issue
the lack of ground-level space we talked
about how in the periphery of New York
City and Staten Island Randall's Island
you have more open space but in
Manhattan Brooklyn part yeah mostly
Manhattan Brooklyn Queens space is more
limited so the lack of ground-level
space is an issue physical challenges
Sam mentioned oftentimes the soil is
contaminated by heavy metals so a lot of
times the soil needs to be imported
there's also shade from nearby buildings
which is a challenge for growing in the
city and like we mentioned this is
hellgate farm they're going on a quarter
acre on a rooftop and primarily produce
hot peppers that is formed into
value-added products like hot sauces and
pepper infused honey and interesting
products like that again a space is a
challenge within CEA operations the cost
of space is a high barrier of entry
regulation and building codes kind of
understanding what's permissible and
what's not
so within soy based operations
oftentimes operating on limited funds
this leads to low salaries the cost of
living is really high in New York City
so often times it also leads to fire
manager turnover so that makes it
difficult for us to because they're
within one season there could be too far
managers at a site and so there's that
kind of differentiates or like extension
work in the city versus in a rural
context where if we were upstate we'd be
primarily working with farm owners and
building that relationship over time but
with the farm manager tone turnover
there's also loss of institutional
knowledge and kind of have to start over
all over again so that makes it
difficult for us and also I'm sure for
the organization's as well
this also leads to difficulty in
investing infrastructure and just sort
of scaling up the operation this is a
picture of the youth farm in Brooklyn
and they're actually using the front
space of a high school funds is like I
mentioned within the CEA operations as a
high startup cost difficult to enter the
space the returns may be too little or
too late in terms of some of the
investments that are that have been made
by venture capitalists knowledge so this
is the third mean category of the
challenges in New York City there's sort
of two backgrounds and mindsets of
gardening versus production and there's
a steep learning curve in terms of what
you need to know to be able to sell to a
market so oftentimes there's just a gap
in knowledge about efficiency and
marketing so that's sort of lacking with
gardeners that come into this space and
also just learning technical skills on
the fly and just having a general sense
of the technical production knowledge
that's needed
this is a beekeeping workshop in the
Bronx we have a group called crafts in
New York in New York City and crafts
stands for collaborative regional
Alliance for farmer training so this is
one way that farmers are started getting
the technical knowledge and doing
peer-to-peer learning and learning from
other operations in the city and again
knowledge within CEA operations there's
a sort of a lack of information sharing
so there's a sphere of within tech
growers that they're sort of reinventing
the wheel and this comes from having
proprietary mindset a lot of these
companies are really tech companies and
so they just come at it from a different
perspective and oftentimes this results
in the lack of experienced growers and
decision making roles folks that have a
lot of that experience managing larger
scale operations test pests and disease
pressure so at least in New York City
some of the most common insect pests
that we saw were flea beetles and
Harlequin bugs on brassicas to spot a
spider mite on tomatoes and other crops
and as well as foliar diseases bacterial
spot on tomatoes and bacterial bacterial
speck on tomatoes and bacterial spot on
peppers and really in the city there's a
big focus on organic controls and that
sort of follows in line with the values
and the mission of a lot of these
operations so they tend to be more
organic than conventional this is a
Harlequin bug on broccoli and this also
just shows the differences with upstate
New York with upstate and downstate some
of the pests and disease pressures are
different given the warmer climates so
next steps right now we're taking on
both shared and individual projects so
providing individual ta technical
assistance to urban growers sometimes
through email but other times through
social media a big platform for us is
Instagram we find that that's where
we're able to do the most
reach to our target audience and also
focusing on production oriented
workshops and small group learning as we
head into the winter and this is sort of
the downtime for farmers we're entering
that grower meeting season I'm taking on
food safety
some CEA controlled environment
agriculture operations are focusing on
GAAP certification so that they can
enter new markets Sam is going to
continue his work on soil survey and
yeah so this photo right here is vets
and vets dye campaign against hunger
it's there Saratoga farm in Brooklyn and
this is an example of on-site ta so us
going out and helping farmers
individually in person so next steps a
few upcoming projects this is a picture
of a mushroom workshop at La Finca deals
for and in the Bronx I'm continuing work
on specialty mushroom production in the
city so I've applied to a couple federal
grants to create a network of mushroom
educators throughout New York City we're
also trying to connect CEA growers sort
of fostering more collaboration and
network sharing amongst this group that
tends to be our priority area based so
that is done you like through meetups
and roundtables we're also trying to
find more sites for research and field
trials as well as well as developing a
newsletter where we can sort of continue
to do this outreach to our network and
our target audience of commercial
growers in the city and so this is our
Instagram handle we have over 500
followers right now and our email
addresses and yeah that's about it
[Applause]
okay so the question was about markets
and the different marketing outlets that
these operations sell into so it really
varies from operation to operation but
I'll give you an example Brooklyn Grange
has a farm stand like on the weekends
and so folks come up to the rooftop and
buy their produce there they also have a
CSA I don't know how big that CSA is
they also sell to a company called local
roots NYC that's an online CSA website
and online buying platform and actually
it's interesting in their third site in
Sunset Park a school knew that they were
opening up and so they asked them to
start a CSA for the school so just sort
of with that brand recognition and the
publicity that they get around being in
a city sometimes folks come to them for
CSA and it's like a lot of other things
or like the sort of general theme of
these urban agriculture in New York is a
no to operations being the same and so
they're all these sort of creative
marketing approaches people are taking
so I got from greens you point out
before is on top of the Whole Foods and
they just walk it down into those foods
most places obviously don't have that
more often it'll be on site yeah farm
stands a lot of the nonprofit's so that
way and the a lot of the nonprofits have
CSAs and I think a lot of times that's
partly just because it's a way of
engaging the community it's not
necessarily the most profitable way they
get rid of stuff because now you're
growing all this squash and stuff that
takes up a lot of space but it gets
people engaged and yeah you don't see a
lot of urban growers at green markets
probably because of scale and a lot of
cases or because they already have their
markets bend down like that the
higher-end places are selling directly
to restaurants a lot of time so like
Gotham greens or like I'm Brooklyn
Grange I mean so I mean that's a huge
market in the city there chefs like to
buy directly and and to have to be able
to say we bought from somebody down the
street is you know when it when local is
a big thing that's hyper locally you
know you the only one who gets to say
that you bought stuff in from somebody
in the same borough that you're in and
some restaurants have Gardens on the
rooftops and a couple of them have sort
of like a small like a like a Market
Garden on the rooftop we haven't worked
with them as much yeah restaurants I've
mentioned that one but restaurants make
up a huge portion of the sales a lot of
times what the advantage is okay I think
we sort of touch a little bit of on that
I think a lot of it is just sort of like
this cool factor and it's novel and it's
different and so they can kind of play
up on that in terms of the mark in a
marketing sense and it's not just local
it's hyper local and the advantage is
that it also allows people to sort of
learn more about where their food comes
from how it's grown and really engaged
with the food system so there's that
aspect as well yeah and most of these
farms I guess you wouldn't probably say
that somebody just went to New York City
in order to start a farm necessarily
maybe with some of the indoor or some of
the startups and in that case it's
probably about being close to Talent or
having you know about the people that
they're hiring and that's where those
people want to live but for a lot of the
projects it's that people work this is
where they were already living and in a
city of eight and a half million people
it's hard to find a way to sort of you
know if you want to get out and get your
hands dirty
it can be tricky to find that and there
are community gardens but a lot of it
seems like it's people who already lived
there and want to do something but they
don't want to move out of the city so
figure out how to farm in the city
mm-hmm it's not it's not a place that
you would probably travel from far and
wide because it's the best place to farm
you know like it's got a lot obviously a
lot of challenges okay so the question
was with a lot of these operations if
they're any farm owners or are they
primarily renting or leasing the space
primarily renting or leasing the space
they work out some sort of contract or
negotiation with the building owner and
that arrangement looks different with
every operation there was a hydroponic
facility on top of a portable housing
unit a building owner in the case of
Gotham greens is Whole Foods so they
have their own relationship Hellgate
farm that picked that photo that I
mentioned where they're growing peppers
hot peppers that's like it was like
through a friend I'm trying to think of
other arrangements
it's hard to think of any case where the
operator owns the land land is just
really expensive and there's I'm not
sure mathematically you can make it work
as a business if you need to purchase
the property first
except maybe there might be some areas
around the fringes or something
it's unless there's some sort of support
for that and there isn't it's something
we've talked about a little bit with
some people is this idea of you know
what would AG preservation you know
restrictions look like in New York City
but I'm chuckling but it's a real
question like maybe we could maybe there
is something around maybe there could be
something that looks like purchasing
development rights or something that
that makes a an incentive to actually
farm somewhere and maybe even own the
land but
as it is it's long-term ideally
long-term lease arrangements is the best
that most people are yeah most people
can get and yeah that's mostly what it
is oh what's so good just a lot of it is
on parks land that's what one of the
common probably the most common like
landowner for these operations and so
the community gardens very often are on
parks land green thumb is part of parks
but also parks owned some properties
that were sort of grandfathered into the
green thumb program that were bigger and
that are community farms or nonprofits
and there are a couple of examples of
for-profit farms that are on parks lands
as well yeah and also um I was just
gonna make comment about we've taught a
farm so the example that I gave up
Brooklyn Grange been flaner the director
of agriculture there and the co-founder
he did a lot of cold calls so he sort of
focused on areas that would be able to
have the adequate weight bearing
capacity so he folks first had a
location in Long Island City and then
the second one it was in the Navy Yard
so focusing on buildings that can
withstand that kind of load and it was
really just cold calling just there's no
like directory to really go off of yeah
so they were part of the 25 yeah I don't
know if they were included in the 25 but
we definitely did visit a lot of the
tentacle gardens where we didn't mention
this but we are co-located with the USDA
and Agra markets on the same floor and
our building at 55 pounds in in Fort
Greene and I'm trying to think of
specific collaborations are probably so
many right now there are too many yeah
yeah
our time is talking with with
stakeholders all over the city and it's
very often I mean you're mentioning like
working food insecure neighborhoods so
it's very often it's justice oriented or
social justice racial justice sort of
all combined into food justice um
that's maybe the one of the biggest
umbrellas of the different organizations
we work with and I know they're probably
at least 20 that we could rattle off but
also and then there's also other farmer
other sort of farmers support that was
in place so there's community garden
support green thumb being the biggest
player there and we're we're mostly sort
of letting them do that because they're
like we said there are hundreds of
community gardens so that two of us
would be pretty tough for us to keep up
with that and green thumb sort of has it
covered in any ways but there's also
grow NYC which is a city program they
have a program called farm roots which
is a farmer training a farmer training
initiative that they've had for a number
of years and there's a program called
the farm school which is another sort of
urban farmer training program and so
those are both sort of in place from run
as you know they're nonprofits or city
programs for farmer training where it's
still there's such a big city that
there's room there's a lot of room for
you know for more players and so part of
what we've been doing in working with a
lot of these stakeholders is figuring
out how we can support them and that as
we enter the space where a lot of people
have already been a lot of our role
right now is support for all sorts of
other groups figuring out how we can
support other groups rather than trying
to do what they're already doing yeah I
mean we've been working with some
Botanical Gardens I mean they sort of
have their own gardening they're another
place that work more with gardeners I
guess then and farmers but we've
definitely been visiting them and we
have we have people we work with there
yeah USDA I guess less directly but we
do we do have USDA FSA on our floor who
works with a lot of the same people that
we
so we do collaborate there so the
question was on what the mission is of
these mission based groups right and if
it's what were the examples that you
were saying yeah a lot of it is so the
one one of the big missions is food
access is growing food to either either
just to be donated or to be sold at a
lower price than you'd normally find it
and also to go culturally appropriate
food so that's where like amaranth and
bitter melon and things like that come
in you stuff that's hard to find the
grocery store that the surrounding
community really would like to have and
has been asking for and so yeah amaranth
is a really popular thing and so that's
why it's a food access being one part of
it access to healthy food a lot of that
is educational and that's the other sort
of overlapping big mission is education
so there's a lot of youth programming a
lot of summer programs you know summer
obviously lines up nicely with the
growing season so there's a lot of
summer programming on a lot of these
farms I want to say probably most of the
nonprofit's have some sort of summer
youth programming where kids the high
schoolers or younger are there you know
working on the farm every day and by the
end still a lot of overlap between the
different missions and so and they're
served general admissions of empowerment
of empowering the local community and
providing green space and providing a
public space writing providing gathering
places yeah like two examples that come
to mind one is the nonprofit like sister
organization of Brooklyn Grange is
called City growers and so they host
educational tours for school-aged
children to come primarily from
low-income public housing neighbor
so that's one example Randall's Island
bird farm they're located close to
Harlem so they focus their educational
tours and their mission is outreach to
that community and you mentioned
workforce development and that is one as
well right next to Randall's Island
urban farm is a project eats Ward's
Island they have a lot of program like
sort of job training programs for
returning citizens so there's a like a
culinary program there on the island and
men who've recently recently
incarcerated men will come and and a
couple days a week will come and do job
training stuff there I wouldn't say that
we have hard numbers on that but we do
ask and when we you know sort of bring
up this question um have you tested your
soil people the first thing that they
think of is they're thinking a test for
heavy metals they're not thinking about
nutrients at all so that's something
that's very much on the forefront of
their minds but I would say most of
operations have tested their soils we
just don't know exactly how many yeah I
mean the the common approach is to
assume that your soils contaminated
right and to just bring it right off the
bat you know maybe put down landscape
fabric and bring in soil on top of it
that's probably the most common approach
and that's sort of the that's worthy of
the the community garden approach of the
green thumb general approach now and I
think since they're so intertwined
especially with a lot of nonprofit farms
that people replicate that as a best
practice but ya know it's it's that's a
big sort of ever-present question for
all the soil based folks starting to
finds the materials of
that's a good lead-in project yeah that
we're starting to connect with so that
okay so first the question if they're
having trouble accessing stuff accessing
growing medium generally I think I mean
that's why people grow in out percent
compost is because they can get it for
free the city you can drop it off maybe
it might not be dropped off when they
want it but they get it and it's free
and they don't have to pay hundreds or
thousands of dollars to have it
delivered in from nursery out of the
city so there's that it was just another
just having the money but so there's a
good project that's being started up
called the what's called pure soil NYC
but build on what's called the clean
soil bank that already exists in the
city no back yeah is there slime yeah it
was early on when we talked about manual
labor that's right
that's where we were working on yeah
that's what this is right
so this was a this is a test site so
okay I'll back up the clean the clean
soil bank is a project that sort of
already existed in the city it was being
being rolled out which is which wasn't
for growing space it was just for clean
fill so the idea being that the topsoil
if you assume that the top however many
feet are contaminated that below that
because lead especially isn't that
mobile soil that if you go deep enough
it's not going to be contaminated and
yeah it's clean in that way right hence
the name so for people who needed to do
like build a berm in front you know by
the ocean or there's something needed
who needed fill material that they knew
was was free of contaminants then they
would get stuff being dug up from a
foundation of a construction site which
is obviously it's happening all the time
all around the city there's all this
clean so being dug up and being hauled
out of the city and dumped in and up
somewhere in new jersey probably we
assume it's almost the second stone and
and so it just gets trucked out of the
city and then trucked back in for people
who are needful so they were setting up
this Bank to connect them directly so
that it would go to
from one site to another it's not much
used for gardeners because as soil is
you know totally free of organic matter
basically and and you know lifeless
essentially and so this idea for the
pure soil and when I see that the
governor's off to the I'm not government
the mayor's yeah office of environmental
remediation is is putting together is to
take that soil take this sort of like
best that they can find at that soil not
exactly sure how that's figured and
makes it with compost and then deliver
that for growing in so that's what's
happening here we're helping to mix that
mix the clean field that's a I think a
pile of the fill with compost and so
somebody that we that we've worked it's
a little bit in the city's it was doing
this trial trying like zero percent
compost you know ten twenty thirty and
see and growing stuff in and seeing the
difference and you definitely can see
the difference zero percent does not
it's not work very well although a
little bit better than you'd expect but
not very well
and so up there so finding that sort of
like sweet spot of what's the ratio of
course the compost and the fill are not
uniform around you know the sources are
not gonna be uniform so it's all gonna
be a little bit approximate but we want
to weave in try anyways to work with
them and we're talking about maybe some
some field trials to figure out like how
to make use of that soil and how how can
you make that work it's not we're not
gonna come in and say don't do it cuz
they're gonna do it we want to come in
and figure out how we can help make it
work yeah yeah places being located near
cultural communities are constraints
[Music]
in terms of community gardens or the
commercial operations are both just why
so much of Brooklyn kind of a desert
there's so many so for community gardens
well so that big empty area in southern
Brooklyn is more sort of yards and it's
just different it's a I mean we've been
wondering the same thing
yeah to extent yeah and yeah just
looking at it now like Bay Ridge
Sheepshead Bay they're tense it tends to
be more presidential and you would think
that there would be more urban AG
happening in those areas but I think I'm
not really sure the cluster but the
cluster of so the clusters in the Bronx
Harlem and central and eastern Brooklyn
correspond very closely with the earlier
crazy colored map that those are
historically black communities that were
present day and historically and so a
lot of work has been focused there
because those are areas that had been
systematically underserved for for
decades and so now that's one thing is
that that people you know sort of in
some cases pushing back against
development and gentrification is a huge
huge factor in a lot of these places
have gone into neighborhoods where
people had started up their own
community gardens in a lot of cases I
mean the Bronx definitely but also in
Brooklyn people had started up their own
community gardens and just vacant lots
and then developers that started to make
the surrounding community more desirable
and developers started want to move in
and of course the open spot is the
garden and so that's one of the ways
that that the community garden movement
has played a really big role in the city
is in basically just fighting developers
they've been fighting against developers
for you know 40 or 50 years now so I
know that's sort of a long long way
around it but yeah and when you think
about historically community gardens
were sort of like a reaction of the
economic crisis happening in the 80s in
New York City and so a lot of times it
was just it was survival it was trying
to have some open space so that you can
grow your own produce and just be able
to survive in really difficult times
one more question and I just like to ask
what are your hopes for York City in the
next five years that's a big question
you know well um
something that comes to mind there's a
lot of work right now happening in the
policy realm so we would hope to see at
least for me and maybe I could speak for
you is bridging this divide between
civil based groups and CEA controlled
environment agriculture groups so there
tends to be this divide where a you know
mission-driven versus profit-driven
and it has been at times contentious so
we would like to see within the next
five years those groups working with one
another and collaborating and not being
so divided yeah that's a big bit that
was something we started noticing
I mean before we even started our job
and has been a constant sort of presence
in in our work yeah and maybe just a
sort of stability I guess in in
something that would give in this was
also sort of would go to policy I guess
but if we're talking about hopes
community gardens have this challenge
but a lot of the soil based farms as
well like just tenure just because you
could don't own the land a sort of
tenuous situation and exists there and
then on top of that just the funding
challenges so for the mission different
farms funding is a challenge in almost
every case if not every single case and
so if there's you know maybe a more
secure funding stream or something and
and we we look for you know how we can
help all these projects and if they're
bottom if it's for property we're trying
to help the bottom line a lot of times
that's sort of an easy that's you know
easy way for us to everything for us to
focus on but with the nonprofits that
I'm talking about it more cuz it's sort
of it's a little more complicated I
guess we're just trying to figure how we
can support like what does it support
look like if the end goal is more about
just staying open or about or if there's
a justice mission like how do we support
that mission yeah I don't know I have a
lot of questions and I have a my hope in
five years is to have answers to all the
questions I just have yeah this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu